[Music]
over the past 25 years Shawn Brock has
risen to the top of the culinary world
he's the founding chef of the restaurant
husk in Charleston South Carolina named
the best new restaurant by Bon Appetit
in 2011 HUS now has four locations
across the south brach has one two James
Beard Awards released two best-selling
cookbooks and is featured on the Netflix
series chefs table this year at the age
of 41 he walked away from it all we met
up with him at his home in Nashville I
was under the illusion that I was you
know unbreakable at his peak chef and
southern food evangelist Sean Brock was
operating eight restaurants in five
cities including the acclaimed husk it's
so fast-paced and it's so stressful that
you'd lose access to the part of your
brain where all the rational
decision-making occurs and so you just
keep making mistakes over and over and
it's easy to get trapped in that tornado
and you were trapped in it I was in the
center of that tornado I was conducting
it Brock admits he was a workaholic it
strikes me that you're you're pretty
obsessive about everything you do yeah
his body was shutting down in 2016 he
was diagnosed with a chronic autoimmune
disease that can be aggravated by stress
my immune system started attacking
itself I woke up one day with with
double vision and you can't use a sharp
knife with double vision and you can't
juggle flaming hot pins and that was the
first time in my life where I kinda had
my hands tied he was frustrated angry
and drinking his friends and family were
alarmed especially his mom Renee were
you worried a few years ago absolutely
cuz his dad you know was a workaholic
and he dropped over from heart attack at
39 so
I held my breath until he reached 40 I
literally held my breath I turned there
was a period of time I didn't know him
he was just he was you didn't recognize
him
you look great you were a different
person telling different person weren't
you completely what had happened
alcohol yeah it's different close
friends intervened and Brock went to
rehab even when you know you have to
change sometimes it can be very hard to
change I think that's why the universe
didn't give me a choice do you like
yourself better now yeah absolutely
I've never been happier healthier or
better cook than I and than I am now how
does it change your cooking being
healthy and being happy is allowed me a
clarity that I didn't know existed
honestly this year he packed up his
knives you walked away from Husker which
is something you spent a lot of time
creating and when you a lot of accolades
it's something that a lot of people were
very confused about to build something
up and put so much time into it inferred
to be so successful and so important and
just to be able to walk away from that
was an incredible gift that I gave
myself Barak hasn't worked in a kitchen
in a year instead he got married and had
a son Leo I tried to buy all my food
here and visits the Nashville farmers
markets regularly that's a formidable
potato I'm gonna buy some because my son
Leo likes sweet potatoes the first time
I made food for Leo was pretty pretty
humbling pretty embarrassing why what
happened so I had this idea that I would
come here and pick out like 15 to 20
different varieties of squash or so you
can say this and line up all the spoons
for him to taste each one yeah he is the
gag
I gotta get these Peas
so this is my friend Thomas over here
he's the king of peas with his pea
machine taste that that vibrancy that's
the way the food has always tasted in
the south it's the food that I grew up
with over the years unfortunately a lot
of this flavor got bred out these Peas
inspired the chicken and dumplings
recipe in his new cookbook South
published this fall these are fancy
dumplings
cuz I can't make yours it's a
celebration of the unheralded
Appalachian cuisine Brock says runs
through his veins absorbed growing up in
his grandmother's garden in Virginia
coal country ever had leather britches
leather britches maybe men know about
sake beans sake beans today he has a
vegetable garden inked onto his arm
how long did it take you to get that put
on like 250 hours Wow really
this food will be the star at his
upcoming restaurant project in Nashville
where Brock will also try to transform
the restaurant business the way he's
done his own life I think it's time in
this industry it used to be your
decision making was based around what
you're capable of doing think how far
can you push it now it's more what can
we achieve while staying happy and
healthy the mental and physical wellness
of the team will be paramount you're
trying to change the culture effectively
well in the industry we bend over
backwards all day every day to take care
of the guests and in the mean time we're
breaking ourselves you've described this
as kind of the second act of your life
it really is this is the restaurant that
I'll serve my last meal in this is the
restaurant where I'll clock out for the
final time
that's quite a transformation his two
restaurant project named after his
grandmother Audrey opens next spring it
will have a shorter menu to alleviate
stress on staff a special lighting
system that will also be a soundproof
sanctuary room for staff to decompress
meditate or seek other distressing
Fairly I like how he's thinking yeah so
she
bring him on I can't wait to go the new
restaurant it's so interesting with him
because even though you realize he's
changed when you see what he did for his
son in terms of lining up to 15 spoons
bones you know he's still obsessive
about everything he does food look
really I went off the screen I want to
say I've never eaten beans like those
beans I love when his mom was rubbing
his back when she was talking to him
clearly it's very tender between that
was it was a tough period that they got
through